Welcome to the journey
so grand.
Lines of code we start to weave.
In this world, we do believe Daytona
shining through the night.
Local magic,
pure delight.
Ivan's wisdom lights the path.
Steering clear of coding wrath
with this
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we continue our Rawkode live series where
we take a look at future facing cloud
native technologies to simplify your cloud native journey.
Today is no exception. We are joining
the well, blah. Let me try and find
the words. I am being joined by the
Daytona team to take a look at simplifying
your development environments.
Joining us today
is
Ivan.
Hey, man. How's it going?
Pretty good. Thank you. Great to have you.
It's always fun to have these,
what, blurbs in the video so people know
it's, like, real. It's not prerecorded. So, like,
everything that we're doing is live. Everything that
we screw up,
you know, it happens. It's like so it's
great. I was just talking when we were,
before we got live, it's like, I do,
like, a demo a day at least. And
then I was, like, at a huge conference.
A thousand people are watching, and my demo
broke. So, you know, it is what it
is. So it's live. So welcome, everyone. Super
happy to be here.
Yeah.
As as
said previously, I've done over 432
of these, and there's probably 900 errors at
least. So
those those those are really making fun. Anyway,
for anyone who's not familiar, let's start with
you. Can you give us a little bit
of information on who you are and what
you've been up to? Sure. My name is
Ivan, cofounder and CEO of Daytona.
Did a bunch of things in my career.
Probably what's relevant to the conversation that we're
having right now is that the cofounding team
of of Daytona, which is about fifteen months
old now,
was also the cofounding team of Code Anywhere.
So Code Anywhere was the, as far as
I fact checked, I always say this a
bit, the very first browser based IDE
ever in the world.
And so we did that in 02/2009 before
there was web two point o. Just to
be clear, there was no, like
there was no nothing you could really do
in the browser then. It was basically a
white notepad and FTP server and whatnot FTP
connector. As WebPoint two came out, we could
do syntax highlighting and all these things in
the browser. So we
sort of were the first that started this
whole journey into bringing,
you know, dev environments
off the local host or, let's say, at
least trying to simplify them least successful before,
hopefully,
more successful this time around?
Yeah. I mean, I think that's really important.
I mean, if we look at the landscape
today and cloud native development with microservices
and, you know, polyglot runtimes and languages and
our services and databases
from every other new startup vendor, like,
local environments is probably in fact, they're not
possible anymore, you know, depending on what magic
people are trying to work out. But I
think cloud based environments are where we need
to be, and I'm hoping that we can
show people a really good way to do
that today.
Yeah. I mean, it so so
I was just gonna add on that, though,
like, I feel that history has changed quite
a bit. I mean, back in the day
there's back back in the day. But, like,
back in my day, we used IDEs,
and the name basically meant integrated dev environment
because
you had, like, Eclipse or IntelliJ or Visual
Studio and installed everything on there. And when
you wrote code, you hit run, it worked
because it had all the dependencies that you
needed there for the most part. Whereas, like,
fast forward today, because of everything we've done,
microservices and whatnot, like, you can't do these
things
or you can't have a prepackaged
IDE for that. So, basically, we mostly most
of us use Versus Code, which is just
a text editor on steroids.
And now the complexities of setting up the
dev environment is off on you or us
or me and whatnot. And so we're hoping
with Daytona to get a bit of that
feel and magic back where it's, like, as
simple as it can be, and you just
focus on the coding and let, you know,
offset all the dependencies to someone else.
Nice. I mean, I'm sold already. But, anyway,
we should still do the demo, I think.
Now I've got some questions for you, but
I'm gonna let Kanal head in first because
he beat me to the punch, and it's
relevant to what you said. He wants to
know what conference you're going to next.
So what conference? I have not booked conferences.
So to be fair, the last conference I
was at was shift shift in Croatia because
I found that one. It's not mine anymore,
but I found it. So I went.
And there's so many conferences to go to,
and I'm basically a conference junkie. It's just,
like, trying to eat heads down.
That means for CubeCon, though. Come on. Right?
You go to CubeCon? Exactly. I was gonna
say, like, I'll probably show up at CubeCon.
Like, I might not we're not gonna do
anything, but I'll land and, like, hang out.
So, I'll see you at CubeCon most likely.
Yeah. Nice.
Alright.
What's your favorite programming language?
Not to put you on the spot, but
I'm putting you on the spot. Yeah. You're
putting me on the spot. So what I'll
answer this in a specific way. I'll say
Daytona uses Go.
And The cloud data quality is to just
give you a tick. So Yeah. So we
use Go.
This is for the open source
product. And for now, it's just a CLI
tool. So everything's written in Go. It's just,
one language.
Go is super easy or,
you know, as can be, and it let
us lets us it's a standard in or
very commonly used in
cloud native
products or services that you'd find. So the
type of person that will hopefully contribute or
whatnot is already very familiar, and it lets
us do a lot of things on the
hardware level, which we have to manipulate to
have these dev environments. So
that's my answer, and I'll keep it at
that.
Alright. I mean, most people are used to
me saying Rust 15,000 times in every episode,
and I'm a big fan. But I I've
gotta be honest. I've been playing a lot
with Zeke lately, and there's a lot there
too. So
I mean, a lot of people when when
they ask me this is like, well, like,
Rust, like, why aren't you guys using it
and whatnot? And then it's like,
I'll
I'll go back to my old answer, but,
like, yeah, I don't wanna open up that
can. It's definitely a thousand paper cuts. I
love what Rust gives you, but I've I
always feel like I'm like, why is this
the key? Why do I need to jump
through all of these hoops just to do
that thing? And, of course, it's because it's,
you know, all these data risk protections and
memory safety. Sometimes I just wanna get stuff
done. Anyway, I'm not getting into a rant
today. That's not that's for another time.
Alright. We've heard about you.
You're maybe gonna go to KubeCon at least
for a beer or two.
What is Daytona?
So Daytona
is a dev we call it a dev
environment manager.
Some people use the term CDE, so cloud
dev environment.
But for us, specifically, when we're thinking about
Daytona and how to build it and why
we actually got that, that's a whole interesting
story in itself, how we decided to build
this thing out. But when we did do
our research before actually forming a company, we
looked at
I researched at everyone that had mentioned remote
dev environment or CDE
on the Internet. And so there's, this huge
notion table with, like, all these people. There's,
like, 500 people on the list. And from
there, you'll have, like, investors
and founders
and, you know, users, engineering managers, whatnot.
And what I also found from that is
engineers
that have built or are working on a
similar product inside of their own company because
there's not people say if you search, like,
cloud development, there's a bunch of vendors. Yes.
Maybe. But actually to solve a problem for
a large enterprise are very, very few. I'd
say, like, maybe one.
And so a lot of these companies had
to build it, and that was interesting because
I found that, you know, obviously, Google, Meta,
Shopify,
LinkedIn,
Stripe,
Palantir, like, all these companies have built something
similar internally, and I wanted to figure out,
like, why what's what has been the reason,
for that. And so I reach out to
these people. Half of them, like, reply, and
half of them, you know, have a call
like this with me. And I asked them,
what are you building? What is the problem
that you're solving? How many people are building
it? Do the developers like it? And I
found that
some companies mandate it because of security reasons.
Like, everyone has to use these
standardized
dev environments, be it local, remote, whatever.
And
the ones that don't,
like, it's not a it's not mandated by
the company, but you can choose to use
it and choose not to use it.
80% and this has been consistent of all
these kind 80% of developers actually use it.
So I was like, oh, this is awesome.
Like, developers like this thing, and enterprises are
building this. The teams that are building it
are anywhere from four people to, like, 30
people. So it's not an insignificant amount of
cost of headcount that's actually building these things,
which was, like, super for us. But what
I was gonna get to is the the
most interesting one for me was Shopify.
And so the person that I talked to
at Shopify
told me the story about how they got
to these dev environment standard standardized remote dev
environments.
And so they started first with standardizing the
local dev environments.
And so what they would do is before
if you were new hire,
they the engineering team or they his team
would take the laptop, and then they'd install,
configure everything for you so that when it
was your first day of work, you can
contribute to day one on day one because
everything was, like, set up for you, which
was, like, pretty cool, especially when you have
lots of developers.
And what they noticed is that and this
is his words, not mine,
that
at one point, the cables connected to laptops
were starting to melt because of the size
of these machines that they had to now
spin up and run. And so I it's
in one of my pitch decks. It's like,
you know, this person said that. And so
they had to go out and build these
remote
dev environment systems because, you know, other the
only way to do it now is, here's
an EC two and go figure out how
you're gonna get this up and running. And
so they had to rebuild this whole automation
that they had on the local machine, and
they did it for the for the remote.
And halfway building it, they figured out, oh,
we've already done this before. And, basically, what
they created
the the output was what a developer sees
now is they have the CLI tool,
and I don't know the exact command, so
don't don't don't hold me to this. But
it's basically like create
dev environment remote or create dev dev environment
local. Like, it is the same flow for
an engineer to spin it up on their
local machine
as it is to spin it up on
the remote machine. So you as developer don't
have any difference. Like, if you're doing, a
front end app, super small, super quick, whatever,
you're gonna do a local host. You don't
care. But if it's, like, something large, you
know, have a bunch of services or whatever
it may be, or, like, I'm just trying
trying to help you out, and I don't
wanna shut off my dev environment at my
machine. I can just spin this up automatically.
And what they built was basically the foundation
of what or our first principle of Daytona.
It is a lot of these companies create
their solution is a cloud remote dev environment
for everything. Our thought process is
we want all dev environments, and dev environments
are, like, as we mentioned, being made, they're
all over the place. People have different configurations,
setups, locations.
Sometimes it's on a box in their, you
know, in their basement. Sometimes it's on an
e c two. Sometimes it's on a laptop.
It can be everywhere.
Can we unify all this
so it always feels the same for you?
And that is the principle of what Daytona
is. So the idea is that you have
one command, either Daytona create or a button
create.
Daytona does everything for you. We can run
through what that is,
and you always have the same output. You
have a dev environment that that it feels
like it's local host. It is local host.
It's proxy local host no matter where it
actually is,
and that is what we built out. And
we've built it out as an open source
tool for the individual dev can, you know,
use it, runs it on local host, point
to an EC two, can do that, or
digital ocean, whatever. And there's obviously an enterprise
where, you know, you you install it. There's
a whole cluster, and, you know, it manages
all these things that enterprises are, super interested
on. Probably not the people here, but,
so that
is what Daytona is, and I'm happy for
you to dig deeper into those questions because,
obviously, I haven't answered everything.
No. That was
that was plenty of context. I think I'm
I'm I'm with you now. I am curious,
though. When you say that you provision everything,
do I get to use my own IDE?
Yes. Learning number one. Learning number one of
CodeAnywhere.
So for Code, when we were building CodeAnywhere,
there was no Versus Code. Like, that didn't
exist. Right?
And the only way that we can give
you a dev environment or access to it
then because there was no there was no
Versus Code and there was no remote
in Versus Code, which exists in Versus Code
or also exists in JetBrains now and whatnot,
remote dev support. So we had to build
our own ID. So we've built, like, five
versions of a browser based ID, essentially, Versus
Code. It's not on the level of Versus
Code. Obviously, we're not Microsoft. It didn't have
the budget
to do that and, you know, the plug
ins and whatnot. But the learning was
definitely as a developer, I don't want to
use your, you know, your ID, whatever you
built, whatever you think. No. Give me, you
know, my Versus code. Give me my JetBrains.
Give me my sorry. IntelliJ or PHP Storm.
Cursor
is all the rage now. You can use
Cursor. It doesn't matter. Whatever you feel like
using, you can use. The idea is that
there's zero learning curve. It's everything that you've
done historically would be the same, but just
easier.
Yeah. I mean, I I just mentioned it
because, obviously, there's two types of developers. Ones
that just don't care what their tools are
and then some that have spent decades handcrafted.
And I feel like I've spent decades handcrafted
my my tool chain. So what do you
use? And I I work with one enterprise.
Well, right now, I am using Versus Code
because I I just don't think you could
beat that extension ecosystem. It is
huge.
I've got one eye on zed, but I
don't wanna get into the way it's attractive.
I run Nexus on my desktop, and zed
does its own plug in acquisition, which does
not work with Nexus. So I lose all
my LSPs.
Okay. But I'm ready to jump to the
to zed once it works.
Anyway, I I as I was saying, I
worked for one large enter I've worked for
a couple of large enterprise companies, but only
one that specified we had to use a
CDE, a common development environment. And that's what
it was back in the day. This is,
like, 2012.
A virtual machine, a vacant virtual machine that
I had to spin up on my my
laptop
Mhmm. In GUI mode.
So I then got presented this fedora box
with IntelliJ with its lockdown extensions and keyboard
shortcuts. I couldn't change anything, and everybody worked
that way. And I swear I quit that
job after about ten days. I was like,
no. Sorry. Because at that time, I was
a Vim fanboy. I was all over Vim.
Oh, it was horrible. Even just queries in
a VM is not a nice experience. So
No. It's terrible.
I have to I have to say one
of our value props
is and I'm saying it's very much from
a technical perspective is that there's a lot
of companies that use VDI, so virtual desktop
interfaces,
because everything has to be, like, in lockdown
or whatever. Just just the latency
of streaming
my ID or editor, like, I'm not even
gonna talk about, like, disabling all these things,
but just that latency is enough to, you
know, wanna go kill myself. Like, it's like,
I don't wanna do that. And can we
provide the thing is, like, can we provide
that same level of of safety security
while as a developer, it doesn't feel like
I wanna shoot myself? Like, can can we
get to that place in the world, please?
And so that is also one of the
things that we try to do with all
this for sure. So that's since you brought
it up, I wanted to add on that
100%.
Nice.
Well, I think I'm a bit ready to
see Daytona in action, and I think you're
gonna lead us through a stellar demo today.
Right? Let's hope so. Let's let's let's kick
it off. Yeah. Sharing
screen.
Let's share the entire screen right here.
Do we see my screen? We see my
screen.
Awesome.
Screen is here. Great. Just like to start
up really quickly. Everything I'm gonna show you
is part of Daytona open source, which means,
like, everyone can use it, take it, fork
it, do whatever you want. It's Apache two
point o, so, like, actual open source. I
know there's, like, discrepancies on what people think.
So, like, you know, you can do whatever
you want with it. You've not released the
the Torna business source license yet. No? Yeah.
No. We haven't gone that route. Yeah. We
we still I have to say that when
we were built we built out the enterprise
product first and then the end open source
afterwards.
And we actually did it second because we
wanted to be really sure
about how to split these products
in a way that we don't have to,
like, make up licenses later on, pull back
licenses later on, and and whatever. And so
what we discovered and it took us about
nine months of figuring the of this out.
And it's partially legal, partially product, partially, you
know, vision, whatever. And, basically, what we decided
to do is that everything that is interesting
to a single developer,
all of that is part of this repository,
and, you know, it's patch two point o,
and it'll always be patch two point o.
Everything that you as a developer don't care
about,
audit logs,
spinning up clusters,
monitoring
things, disabling it. Like, all of that is
in a different repository, completely proprietary, and that's
what we sell to the enterprise. So,
I
really
strongly believe that we will never have to
go to a point where we, you know,
touch these licenses because of the way we
split it up
split it up between a user and potentially
a buyer. So we're very scared of that.
There's a lot of things going on in
the market right now,
or the last few days. Anyway, Daytona had
to spin it up, to install it. It's
fairly simple. There's a big read. There's this.
I'm on Mac. So, basically, I'm not gonna
install it. I'm gonna hold up real quick.
I will say that I went through the
docs for getting started, I see next instructions,
and that made me very happy. So Didn't
it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's in there. It's
in there. So we're also I can explain
a bit later. Basically, you just hit this.
I'll install it. I already have installed, so
I won't go through it, but it just,
like, automatically installs everything. There's something. And then
when you hit the Daytona command, you're basically
you have this little
little sort of terminal UI that can, like,
walk you through the most needed,
command.
And so to get up and running, basically,
all you have to do is this one
command, which is Daytona create. And I've already
connected my GitHub, and I connected some providers
and whatnot. But so I'm gonna pick up
GitHub repository.
As we said, it will be just a
hello world. Nothing too
nothing too complicated,
but it has enough for to explain everything
that's going on.
So
what I do, it's the workspace name.
So what I've done right now with when
we're building Daytona, we were actually thinking about
can we make Daytona
work from a logical perspective
very much like a Uber? And, like, bear
with me one sec. Or even a Waymo.
Right? Because today,
you can hit a button on your phone.
It's basically where I am, where I'm going,
and what car is gonna take me, and
it takes you. Right? It's like all I'm
in the real world. And even with a
Waymo, there's no driver. Like, that is the
world we live in right now.
And today, like, getting a dev environment automated
seems like a harder task, which is, like,
beyond me.
And so when we're thinking about this, it's
like, how do we do it in a
similar fashion?
So when I wanna spin up a dev
environment, it is where is my project? So
the git repository where where it's at. Where
do I wanna run this dev environment? Like,
is it on my local host, DigitalOcean,
GCP, wherever it may be? And what ID
do I wanna use? Right? So I've I've
set an a repository.
I'm not gonna pick right now, I'm gonna
hit local. I'll do remote later on. My
local it'll spin up a Docker.
And the ID, I've already set. So it'll
just open up Versus Code, and I can
show you a cursor afterwards if you want.
And so what Daytona does is always the
same with a few, variations. And I'll get
to next in one second as well. So
what it does is it will spin up
a if it's a remote, it'll spin up
a VM on a cloud.
But if it's local, it's there's no read
for that. Then it spins up a container
or micro VM inside of those. So on
localhost, it's just like a docker.
It will then check out the repository inside
of that. It'll read through the repository.
And if you have a configuration file, right
now, it supports Dockerfile
and dev container,
but
we have in testing. So it's already done.
Just to show you that's how long it
took.
We have in testing that we can also
read next configuration files. And so if you
have any of these configuration files, it will
spin up everything automatically for you. And so
now that it's
up and running, I could have done dash
c to get up right away.
The project is here. It's been up for
one minute. It's gonna open Versus code, my
local Versus code, obviously, because I'm not doing
anything else. So prefix number Daytona is just
telling it how to open a remote
dev container. Right? It's opening a remote dev.
Even if it's local, it's remote. Right? Because
it's in your in your Docker. And so
what's interesting because this project
is
has a dev container configuration,
it is
off to the races right away. Sorry. I
I put yarn instead of yarn. Apologies.
And so my project is
up and running, hopefully. Like, demos
should be working. It says hello, world.
Here it is. Okay. It's up and running.
So
there's more to this, and I'm just gonna
pause one second. So what it did was
it checked out repository. It read the configuration.
It built the entire
dev environment so that I can come up
and running, and I only had one sort
of command to get it up and running
right away. Also,
it is on local host. What's interesting if
it was remote, I can show you that,
but it'll be also local host. But one
thing that we also have inside of Daytona,
and this is running on my Docker.
If I do Daytona
forward,
what's the port number? I was here. Port
5173?
I think so. Yeah. 5173
Dash Dash public.
Public.
And if I do this,
basically, what you'll get is a QR code,
and you can scan it, or you can
type the whole URL, but it should be
the QR code here. I'm getting my scanner.
Yeah. So here you go. So get your
scanner out and scan this QR code if
you can. We've never had a QR scan
before in over 400 episodes.
Holy sweet. This work. Did you open it
up? Yeah.
Yeah. And so
so what what what happened now is it
adds a reverse proxy even if behind I'm
behind a firewall, I connect it to whatever,
and you basically have your preview environment. So
if I go
down here sorry.
Let's
change this.
Let's change this real quick and say David.
And, also, everyone in the audience can do
this if anyone was looking at it right
now. Hey. That'll be refreshed in real time.
It refreshed on your phone in real time.
Right?
Yeah. Did. Yeah. Yeah. And so what
it does so what Daytona does, it some
people ask me like, oh, don't I have
this in Docker? Well, Docker is missing some
people also called it, and I don't say
that that this is what we are, like
a
a thin layer around Docker. It is all
the things that you need for a dev
environment that are that are missing from just
having a Docker container. It actually solves Workshop
machine because it'll work for everyone everywhere. You
can share it. Like, all these things are
here,
and it works no matter on what infrastructure.
And so while we're this is gonna take
a bit of time, but I'll just show
you this. So this is my DigitalOcean,
my account. And so if I do Daytona
I'll do Daytona create the same repository.
Daytona
create
GitHub.
It's gonna take a bit of time so
we can talk about things, but I just
want it to go load in the background.
Yeah. Don't worry. I've got questions.
Hello?
So same project,
hello world two, and I'm gonna spin it
up because we're in Europe both right now
in DigitalOcean Amsterdam.
And so what is this gonna do? It's
gonna do everything I did right now,
but it's also gonna spin up a VM
or Droplet
in DigitalOcean.
But I will also have the same it'll
also be all local hosts. It'll be the
same commands. I don't care where it is
as a user. I can also share it
to you. Although it's a, you know, a
public, I could have done it anyway. It'd
be a little bit of work. But it's,
like, out of the box, same feel, same
everything
no matter, like, where it's running. And we
have this for EC two, and we have
this for GCP, and we have this for
all these different things. And so as you
can see so it's right here. It's loading.
And so this has nothing to do with
Daytona now. It's it takes whatever time it
takes for VM Yeah. To actually get up
and running.
So, yeah, I'm gonna pause here and let
you now ask questions while this is sort
of spinning.
Good. Because I got stuff on my head.
First, just because the deal stuff is right
in front of us. You mentioned earlier that
once the VM is provisioned, you're then running
a micro VM, something like Firecracker,
and then running the application inside of that.
Do I have the option to run multiple
of those micro VMs inside of a single
machine? Like, if or is it you get
one
yeah. One host. Right
now, the way it's created,
the the enterprise product does exactly what you
said right now. Okay. The open source sort
of we have to get to where we
have to get. So this version right now,
it's one b it's one actual Droplet per
micro VM.
Basically, the micro VM just the reason it's
there is that it abstracts all the Daytona
things that are running in that machine so
that you don't see that in the workspace.
You don't have to think about that at
all. Yeah. You don't basically, you can SSH,
with root access into the VM and then
see that stuff. But, basically, you don't need
to see that stuff because you actually don't
care.
To answer your question, will we support to
to, you know, spin up multiple workspaces inside
of that so you can orchestrate things? Yes.
And that's something that's on, like, very much
very soon road map, but it's not there
right now.
Okay.
Also, just
because that was fresh in my head. We
can now go back to that first example
that you ran locally. Now I noticed that
there's a dev container directory here. I'm assuming
that's what Daytona is using to work out
how to Exactly. This project? Exactly. The only
thing that for Daytona
is
something that doesn't happen on every single repository
is that it checks for a dev container
type configuration file. So if there's a dev
container, everyone is magical. Right? But, obviously, not
all of them have that. And so, one,
we're expanding
the the types of configuration files that we
will support. So as mentioned, dev container,
mix as well is going to be supported.
Flux because, you know, why not? Because it's
there.
Dev file
and
Docker file. So those are the ones that
we plan to support because those are all
basically open standards,
which will enable us to support even more
of these.
What's gonna happen so very a very hint
for today. It's not core to Daytona's product,
but this week, we're gonna launch a open
source project. Hopefully, everyone can help us contribute
to this. It is a AI
well, of course, everything's AI,
tool that will create these types of files
for any repository.
There's still work to be done. It works
on a large number of them, but the
idea is that
because we
depend on that heavily, we'd like that to
be a solved problem in the world. So
then we're creating this, and hopefully, world can
help us get to a place where this
is not an issue. So every single repository
in the world can be
runnable right at the start. Note that if
there is not a dev container or a
mix or whatever inside,
Daytona falls back on a default
workspace,
which has everything.
Like, everything's installed in that one so that
it almost works automatically. Like, I I've had
people, like, test out and say, oh, there's
no dev container, and it works. Well, yes,
because, like, it's a huge machine, and it's
sort of just for the experience part for
that to happen. I'm just showing you the
screen. The meantime, the droplet finished. Now it's
going through the through all the steps that
it would have gone through on the local
host as well. Back to your questions.
Okay. So I'm a I don't know if
this is gonna lean into something that Daytona
doesn't support yet, but I'll throw at you
anyway. Everything I do is in one mono
repository.
So does Daytona give me any way to
either say I'm working in this mono repository,
but just this particular service? Can it handle
a mono repository? Like, what is the best
practice there?
So yeah. So in the sense of mono
everything's one repository, that's the easiest for us.
Alright. The the
the issues that we come up with are
with multiple repositories.
So Daytona supports right now that you can
have multiple repositories
in the same machine,
and that works right now. What we are
working on right now, that was my call
before this this right now, is how do
we make a world where we don't complicate
this simple
flow,
but that you can actually have
a
workspace, a micro VM, a pod, a whatever
for every one of your repositories and that
that they're all sort of connected together so
that you can have that experience. That's something
that we're working on, like, literally right before
this call, but it's not in there.
Okay. But what if the challenge with my
mono repository mono repository is that I don't
have a top level dev container, and in
fact, I have nested dev containers all throughout
that repository?
Is that something You
can pick which one you want to run.
Okay. That's the question. You can pick which
one. Yeah. You can pick, oh, I don't
want this. If I have multiple so let's
say ASTRO is a good repository. They have,
like, a hundred dev containers inside of that.
You can pick which one you want to
actually spin up. Which one you want to
use. Right? And is it possible, I guess,
this
I I don't know how it like,
okay. Let's strap in. So
you've got this Firecracker virtual machine. Is it
possible for you if it's like, you've cloned
my mono repository. So it's quite large. I
don't wanna clone that every single time I
switch between workspaces or packages within that mono
repository. Can I say I wanna go from
my web app to my back end API
now and reload
that without shutting everything down and back up
again?
There's no
no. But but
but there's a way to do that very
fast. So we have something called prebuilds,
which is essentially what it does, it caches
the build of a repository.
So what that means is that you can
spin up you can create a build for
any of the branches or any of the
dev containers or whatnot, And then you can
spin up different
workspaces
of the same with the different builds. And
because the because the build's cached, it's, like,
super fast to get up. It's way faster
than what we're doing right now.
Oh, nice. Okay.
Well, let's talk about that QR code thing
then. I mean, did you build your own
proxy? Are you are you leveraging other open
source? Like, how does Headscale. So it's an
open source tail scale head scale, it's called.
Just
kudos to them for, like, making that. And
so we were using them as a reverse
proxy to be able to do this. The
reason that we wanna do this as well
is because, you know, creating code anywhere, which
are browser based SaaS cloud ID product,
there's a lot of those that happen that
exist right now.
And we wanted to offer that sort of
value without having any cost. So, basically, what
we have here is the same feel. There's
also a will be coming soon just for
some people want it. We want we did
CLI first. And so you have that same
feel as if you're going through, like, a
code spaces. So let's use GitHub. Right? It's
the same. It's like, oh, pick my repo,
pick my ID, enter. You do all these
things. You can share a URL. It's like
it's running in the cloud, but it's not.
So we wanted that whole experience to be
sort of packaged inside of Daytona.
Nice.
Well, it looks like your DigitalOcean one's working.
Right? It is. It looks like it is.
Let's do Daytona code. Let's try this out.
So this is the one running on DigitalOcean.
You can see that here. You can see
here this one's running local. This one's running
on DigitalOcean.
So I'm gonna open this up. It's gonna
open up a new Versus code,
and we should go through the same
flow
even though it's running,
you know, in Amsterdam,
which is not on my machine. Obviously, some
things might be slightly slower. We'll see. Shouldn't
be.
Here we go.
Yes. Alright. Up and running.
And so same, sorry, same flow terminal.
And I'll do
this time, I won't yarn.
I did it right. Did I? And so
what you're seeing right now is that it's
also on my local host.
So it's still running on my local host.
And for me, all the commands I write
are local host even though it's running on
DigitalOcean.
And, also, what you'll notice is that it
moved the port
from 5173
to 5174
because Daytona saw that the port was already
used, and it used the next one that
was free. So it says 5173,
but I'm already using it for my other
project. So it automatically did that, so I
don't have to worry as well. And then
you get that same sort of I wanna
do Daytona
forward
five one seven
four
dash dash public. I'll get the QR code
here,
and you should be able to work as
well.
Alright. You can scan it and see if
it works.
I think at this stage, I'm pretty convinced
it's gonna work. Yeah. Even if it doesn't,
I think it's good. Like, it's like yeah.
Loading, not loading.
Loading or at least
trying to load. To load. At least trying
to load. Yeah.
So we'll see.
Wait. Am I in the right one? No.
No. Here it is.
Might not. We'll double check why that happened.
But in any case but in any case,
everything up until that was the same,
and that should be the same as well.
But, anyway, so what I was gonna show,
the most important part here was that it's
also proxies to local host. It moves the
port if it needs to because I was
still using the other one. If I'd killed
this service that was running on my local,
it would have been to the five one
seven three I was supposed to, not adequately
moved it. So
I, as a developer, like, there's no difference
outside of, like, snag, maybe,
what happened here for a second. But other
than that, everything should feel the same no
matter where it is. And so if even
if I spin up now on an e
c two or if I spin it up
on, like, a physical,
you know, server somewhere,
it always feels the same to me as
a developer.
Okay.
Very interesting. So
I like that it supports module providers.
I can work locally if I want.
It seems to solve that problem that most
people have in a Mac query. I mean,
you're not syncing files across the network here
because you're cloning the repository
on the the remote box, which is very
So
I'm curious to see
well, if do you have, like
let's look at that dev container dot JSON.
Is there anything interesting in there first before
I take us away from it? I mean,
this one's, like, super simple. There's nothing Okay.
It's just an image and
install Yarn or something. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Install Yarn, and there's a Docker file and
a Docker file. It's just like it's a
very simple one. Yeah. I mean, we can
spin up more complex ones, but even Versus
code itself, like, I mean, it can do
that for you. So I don't think there's
that much magic in that. But what we
do is, like, we build prebuild it for
you and sort of deliver it done.
Or we build it for you, but we
can also prebuild it afterwards for you. So
it's automatically done, and you always know that
it works because that machine that it's running
on is always the same. Right? It's not
on my local machine, which can sometimes it's
a Mac, sometimes it's a Linux, sometimes it's,
you know, whatever it might be.
Yeah. I guess so. Yeah. It worked pretty
well. I mean, I definitely wanna try and
kick the tires on it with some sort
of next flake or dev env or flux
and and have it run as magic that
way. It is on our so it's on
our issues to support that. We've tried it.
It works so like
and so when we publish it, I'd absolutely
love for you to kick those tires. The
interesting part about all of these when you
look at it, the the logic behind how
Flux or Mix and
dev container work, it's it it is
the logic behind them is quite similar. So
it was, like, super easy for us to
basically go out and build a version
a builder for each of these. We call
them builders.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if this is something you
use of tackle yet or something you plan
to tackle in the future, but there are
sometimes
very annoying circumstances where even running in local
dev requires access to some sort of secrets
or credentials.
Does Daytona provide any framework or hooks to
be able to get those into the remote
machine?
So you can
forward secrets into the machine.
You can do that. It depends on where
you can give you more explanations. Like, you
can vary for the most simple
problems that you have, but I don't know
if you have anything more
specific.
Yeah. I I I mean, maybe this is
just something that,
you know, I've had a flake. I would
just have in my dependencies that I need
the one password CLI or I need in
physical, and I have to then, when I'm
in the machine, provide that credential.
But maybe there's a way that because what
I'm seeing here, right, is what Daytona seem
to be doing is taking
something
that is normally
cumbersome,
finicky, annoying,
and putting on a very nice developer experience
to the point where it's one or two
commands and it just worked. You know? So
that I'm now looking at, okay, well, what
are the other frustrations that I have when
I'm trying to work with development environments? And
maybe there's a, you know, you can sprinkle
some of that Daytona sauce or whatever to
make secrets acquisition easier in this remote environment.
I'm not sure what that would be. But
Yeah.
Would actually
very much invite you and everyone watching if
you have any of those ideas. Just, like,
open an issue, please, on our git repo
on our GitHub repository,
and we'll definitely take that out take look
at those because you couldn't
I mean, historically, when we started, you couldn't
forward your environment variables or whatever you wanted
to inside the machines or in those other
workspaces, now you can. So, like, as we
as we progress with the product so the
open source product, we launched it in March.
It's now September, so it's still a fairly
short time. It's still not a stable version,
to be clear. Like, there's breaking changes in
the updates that we do do.
Just to be clear, like, it's still not
there, and my engineering team is
basically, I was saying, can we get to,
like, a stable because of whatever reason? They're
like,
no. Like, we can't do that yet. We
want the freedom to be able to move.
We do two launches a week on the
open source version. So it's like there's a
lot of iteration of things happening. And so,
basically, what we wanna do is take away
all of these paper cuts that you have
in a dev environment, and there's so many
of them
because there's so many different dev environments.
And they're not probably gonna be all your
paper cuts, but you're gonna have two of
them. I'll have two. Another will have 10,
whatever it may be. And so can we
sort of, like, take all these paper cuts
and remove them from the world? That is
what we want to achieve.
Okay. I like it. Is there anything else
that you think would be interesting to show
us before we jump back to big face
mode?
I think that, like, for the demo, I'd
like pause it here. I can share, like,
what the graphic interface looks like and what
other things we can do, but I feel
that
because
the idea of dev environments for people is
like, why do I have to do it?
Like, I have you know, I can do
it myself. I can do whatever.
I feel that this leaves the most impact,
hopefully. And
it gives enough that, like, oh, can I
try it? Can I have that same experience
with my project? Right? And if you don't,
I'd love to know why, like, open an
issue, and we'll we'll basically take care of
it as soon as we can because we
wanna tackle all these issues. And the ones
that you mentioned as well, the sense of
can I have multiple
workspaces basically running inside? That's something that's probably
the most common question that we get from
people that we talk to is, like, can
we get that part in there as well?
And so it's not as simple. It's not
straightforward, but, yes, you can, and we hope
to solve that for everyone as well.
Yeah. Just like that that opens up that
interest and approach where I can either
spin up a slightly bigger box and repurpose
it and save some time from the provisioning
versus having to shut it back down and
spin it up. It's certainly not
you know, it's not a deal breaker because
what you're showing is that you can put
a nice user experience, a a good nice
developer experience on top of what is otherwise
a relatively painful problem. So But can we
but still, we want to get that one
as well. Like, can there's no reason again,
I'm I'm using the the self driving car
analogy. Like, if we can get that, like,
there's no reason in the world why we
can't solve your problem. Like, there's no reason.
Right? I think. I think there's just not
enough
there was not enough
of a pain
for a solution historically
because dev environments were not as complicated historically
as they are today.
Alright. Well, we have a question from someone
named thank you in the chat. Okay. Thank
you. I work with Red Hat OCP and
ARO clusters.
I'm not sure what those is it OCP
that I'll come back to that in a
minute.
With observability and monitoring,
can Daytona make my life easier? So I
guess what they're curious about is
can they use
as as OCP Kubernetes?
I mean, I don't even know. I don't
know.
I mean, I think OCP was that project
that tried to do Kubernetes
with no worker nodes and get a control
point. Maybe, thank you, you can jump back
into the comments and let us know. I
have no idea what ARO clusters are. I'm
so sorry.
But, yeah, let's talk Let's talk more, but
if we can get more details on the
question, we'll try to answer.
Yeah.
Alright.
Ravi is saying, so if we install Daytona
with Next, does it still depend on containers?
So it depends on the question.
So if you
if we're talking about do we use next
next, sorry, as a as a configuration,
yes. It still uses containers.
It's just the way that we architect that
we architect these things. I know that next,
the way it works, like, you don't have
to have containers on your machine.
But the way we've
done it is we create we an isolated
container every single time regardless
just to keep
the product as is. You as a user
don't actually see the difference.
You shouldn't see the difference, but the answer
is yes. We do use that. And if
we're talking about the
VMs as well, it'll go up and spin
up VMs, specifically right now with DigitalOcean, and
then it'll it'll build
using the next configuration file, and each one
will be its own separate even though I
understand it could be on the same one.
Yeah.
Alright.
Thank you, Seth. It's just a Kubernetes based
Red Hat product. So maybe let's talk about
I mean, I'm assuming Daytona could be deployed
to Kubernetes and kind of provision to Kubernetes
as a provider.
So there there's two answers to this. Yes.
We will. There's an up and coming provider
for Kubernetes.
So instead of using, like, a Docker container,
it can use Kubernetes and spin that up.
So that's up and coming, and that sort
of falls
into the same, at least for us,
the same problem as how do we interface
multiple
workspaces, sandboxes, whatever inside a a dev environment.
Because if you're looking at it from a
UI perspective,
it is very much similar. So you have,
like, one dev environment that has multiple of
these pods or whatever. And so, yes, there
is a Kubernetes
provider
coming up, but we're just aligning how that's
gonna work with all these different things. So
that's not specific for for each of the
different providers.
Awesome.
Alright. I'm gonna pop us back over here.
If anyone watching has
if anyone watching has I always forget about
those little animations. If anyone watching has any
more questions, drop them in. You've got a
few more few more minutes to sneak them
in. Let's
talk about what's next for Daytona. So you
open sourced this
a little under a year ago. Mhmm.
You're solving common developer or at least simplifying
developer experience
or getting developer environments.
What's next and what are you what's your,
like, North Star? Where do you want to
get to?
So what where we want to get to
is hopefully be a way of work because
it is an open source free tool. Hopefully,
every developer in the world, like, uses
a Daytona command versus, like, whatever they're doing
right now and all the variations of that.
That is, like, what we hopefully achieve at
one time. But even more than that and
I have to sort of add on it
a bit just, like, aligning where the world
is.
There is a lot of
and I'll take a step back before that.
So we launched support for Cursor
last week or the week before that. And
so why we do that? It was, like,
actually very
interesting on how why people looked at it.
And when you look at all the launches,
it's probably one of the highest. The reason
is I don't know if you saw this,
the meme on Twitter or x, whatever,
of, like like, we don't need like, developers
are gonna, like, go away because we have
AI.
And then you have, like, new someone in
a in a in an iMessage sharing, oh,
I made this application, which is not developer.
They said show me, and they send local
host 3,000, basically. Like, I don't if you
saw that. It's like a meeting. It was
all over the Internet, when Cursor line raised
their last round.
And so as you saw with Daytona, there's,
a QR code, but you have to show
your thing. And so we felt that it
was really interesting that we support Cursor because
you can actually get a solution to that
problem. Like, an AI creates whatever or assists
you, and then you can preview it to
something.
And that got a bunch of interest, a
lot of people using cursor, I think it's
our number it's been out the support for
two weeks, and it's by far our number
two IDE. So it's Versus Code and cursor,
like, halfway there, which is quite interesting.
The other thing while we're thinking about all
that is what does the future look like
in general for human and AI developers,
be it fully autonomous or being just code
assist or whatever?
And it seems I've been testing out a
lot of these. So all hands, dev and
AI, and all these others, like, autonomous ones.
And what's interesting for them is if you
have fully autonomous one, it takes some time
to do things. Like, it's not instant. Right?
If you wanna create a complex
product,
whatever it might be, it's gonna take the
AI time. Like, they might know, quote, unquote,
know everything. They might not I'm not gonna
get into that argument at all. That's a
whole conversation on its own. But it does
take time to get something done. And so
if it takes time to get something done,
if you're running that on your local machine
and if that is your full compute like,
you can't do other things. You basically have
to go have coffee and wait for the
thing to do something. Yep.
For me, that doesn't make sense.
Like, the the way it should work is
like, oh, like, oh, AI. Here's a digital
ocean or EC two. Like, go do your
thing. I can spin up 10 of them
because I'm doing 10 different things. And I
also wanna build something on my own because
I'm doing something, or I wanna check out
the repo that that the AI has built,
and I wanna do that. And so can
what does the dev environment look like, you
know, two years, five years, ten years from
now where both human and AI
are creating code? What is the overlap? What
is the difference?
And so those are things that we're testing
out and playing with. It's not an exact
answer to your question. Like, I don't know.
I was like, oh, we're gonna do this
because the whole market as we see him
is, like, fairly new and changes every day.
But I feel that there's a going to
be a even larger need for these standardized
and larger,
you know, dev environments running somewhere else because
of these sort of tailwinds of AI in
there. So there's a lot of thing. Not
saying we're not becoming an AI company per
se. We're not doing anything of that. But
what infrastructure is needed to run this stuff,
basically.
Very cool.
Do you have you used Cursor? I'm just
curious now. Yeah. I have. Is it good?
I haven't.
I mean, it's here. I I mean, I've
used Cursor.
I mean, their selling point, right, is that
they scan your whole code base instead of
just being pinched
at, like, a single file, but I haven't
Yeah. It does. You can do things in
English,
like, or in any other language actually, which
is interesting. Like, you can do it in
French or German or Chinese or whatever. And
it does. So, basically,
I've I've done this demo and done other
demos with Cursor as well where, basically, you
say, oh, chain find the hello world
that shows up when I run the project
and change it to hello, David. It'll go
through and say, oh, it's this file. It's
on this line. Would you like me to
change it? You say yes, and it does
it. So it's like like, it's pretty cool
for those things. I very much believe that
AI is not in a place where it's
like, oh, go build me an app, and
I'm gonna, like, make money off this app.
I don't think it's even close to that
there. But those types of things, like, yeah,
it's, like, super convenient. You don't have to,
like, search or do anything. It's just like,
go do it, and it does it. So
that's great. So you're not gonna be in
the business of when people open issues on
open source, it's on a project of having
Cursa then go implement it, ship a pull
request, merge it?
Not quite yet.
I don't like, maybe for the simple ones,
there's a lot of people that the I've
talked to a lot of the a lot
of companies that are building vary variations of
AI agents, autonomous and, like, assisted.
And there's a lot of them that still
use humans, a lot of them. There are
some that also use so there's startups that
do exactly what you said. It's like, oh,
there's a pull request, then you sort of
assign the AI. It goes out. It spins
up a VM somewhere. It runs. It does
all these things.
But I've also seen ones that do that,
and then a human actually looks at the
code, sort of fine tunes that, and then,
submits a PR. So I've seen those, happening
as well. Fully autonomous, they exist, but it's
also a question of, like, how good is
it. I
can't use it for a lot of things
that we're doing,
but it's also and you'll probably know this
as well where it's AI
does a lot of or AI. I actually
don't really like that word AI for what
what this is right now. I feel like
AI is something like, AGI is more AI.
Anyway,
semantics.
What I was gonna say is that AI
is really good at doing things that we
have done as humans,
you know, before. So if you're gonna create
a crud app, like, that's easy. It's gonna
go do that for you. Like like, anyone
can do that. You just, you know, search
the Internet, how you do it, whatever. But
if you're doing something that has not generally
been done or not in the public, and
if we're trying to fine tune and optimize,
you know, these machines and then, you know,
sticking multiple machines in one machine
in the way that we're doing, like, it's
not gonna,
give you anything
really useful in the sense of, like, an
end to end solution. Obviously, in, like, assistance
when you're, like, typing things and it's trying
to help you, it'll find it. It'll do
those. But actually making something complex that the
world
has not seen or not seen in public,
it's not gonna do that very well.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, I will say thank you, first and
foremost, for building a great open source project.
I feel like the developer management environment space
has been lettered with proprietary software for for
far too long, and it's nice to see
a bit of young fresh blood come in
and shake that up with open source. I
also appreciate the change logs, which are shipping
far quicker than I can keep up with
them. But that level of transparency into what
you're doing as a company and a product
at an open source project is
invaluable. So, again, lots of thank yous for
you and your team and what you're doing.
Any final words before we say goodbye? Just
very much a thank you. This is our
first open source project
product project. We've never done it ourselves. Obviously,
we've consumed other ones, and we're trying. So
if anyone has any comments of, like, oh,
we're supposed to show this or do this,
we're trying like, the road map is in
there. I just had a change lock is
in there.
All the issues, everything's very, very transparent, and
we're trying to do that even though, you
know, it is a company a venture backed
company trying to do something. But this section
of what we've built should be a pure
as pure as it can be open source.
And so if anyone has any, you know,
comments or suggestions, we're all there. Also in
Slack,
we have a fairly large is it, like,
2,000
people, whatever, in our Slack? Happy to have
people join that as well and share with
our comments and tell us what we're doing
wrong or what we're doing great. Like, we
welcome all comments.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for your
time and for guiding us through that demo.
And and to everyone watching, thank you for
spending your evening, morning, or afternoon with us.
We'll see you all next time.
And
gonna
with everyone
underneath
the rising sun.